ホームランチーム
下記人とホラーを打ったときのように元気
に動き回るチームです
ノンバー紹介します
私
マリ
名
正しくは茨月能宗麻痺があり方とが不自由
そして言葉を話すことができません
縁カラーチーム市牟呂メーカーなんです
マリさんです
ダウン症です
彼女は私より背が低くて小さいだけど彼女
が
しっかりしていますそしていろんなことに
気づいて私を助けてくれます
そして姉さんじ a 賞です
彼女が記憶力が抜群ですそして物知り私に
いつも楽しい話を聞かせてくれます
私たちには壁は毛糸ではありません
さぁさぁれる柄3皿売られるからそんなの
はないんです
私たちはできないことをできる人が
補い合い支え合うチームなんです
もともとや私たちは会社の中で障害ある
メンバーでできた部署でした
当時の私たちの仕事が
炎の会
糸島がある自社の欄に中1回行って屋さん
を作ること私たちは週1回しか農園には
行けなかったし野菜の作り方なんか知り
ません
だから最初は野菜なんかできてなかったん
です
そんなときはどうしたらいいのか
私たちは
なぁかの方
そしておい
地元の方に
聞きました沢山野菜の作り方を聞きました
そして私たちの持ち前の明るさ分
次第にの上には人が寄ってくるようになり
火星をしてくれてそして野菜ができるよう
になったんです私達は野菜だけじゃなくて
人とのつながりというのを収穫できたよう
な気がします
そして
できた野菜を
近隣のレストランや商店街で販売をしまし
た
葉っぱ付きの大根
もう新鮮なお野菜
私たちが野菜を広げると商店街の人たちは
みんなよってきました
そして
ホームラン食度週に2体おにぎりなどの
軽食を作ること
私たちにはキッチンはありませんでした
ここは会議室で小さな今後を二つ並べて
私たちはおにぎりの具材を炒めたり磯して
農園の野菜をふんだんに使ったスープなど
を作っていました時にはカレーライスや
ピザと臼と有働
流動
私たちのできるか霧のメニューを頑張って
挑戦をしていました
そしてホームラン新聞
毎月1回新聞を発行すること
こんなん
賑やかな新聞を作っていました
この新聞には私たちのそれぞれのコーナー
は
設けていてまりさんは季節の挨拶文そして
明さんは命の波を打っと出せという
コーナーでいろんな人から悩みを聞いて
ロイさんのユニークな回答でいても簡単に
解決をしましたそしてこの新聞を飾るこの
いらしたらアーティストのかたし君が毎回
楽しく面白く書いてくれたものです
てこの新聞のコーナーの中には天神さんぱ
というコーナーがあって天神近郊のを偽に
取材に行きそのお店の紹介をしていました
私たちはいろんなところに行きました
そしてラーメン屋さんレストラン
うどん屋さん
靴屋さんか早く田植えと大口屋さんと
カバー皆さんそして a 棟
まあいろんなとこ行ったんですけど俊くん
が一番喜んだのは
メイドカフェだよねはいはい
そしてアートイベント
高熊会がとためジャズだったのでみんなで
このような新聞ラックをつくって尚邦赤い
てもらいそして作品をつくってグッズにし
度
ギャラリーで展示会をしたり販売間に呼ば
れていろんなイベントに参加していました
私たちは
その時もうとても大忙しでした
そして
新聞社で繋がったレストランでは art
de ナイトショーを開いていただいて
言葉の話せないたかし君と私との掛け合い
トークで既読ださんとお客さまの心に
何かしら響くものを伝えられたんじゃない
かと思います
この靴下等正しくデザインの幸せの
フレーミングを靴下です
これ
えっ
はいこのカラフルで個性的が靴下等足元
から元気いっぱいになるように世界中の人
が幸せになるようにという願いを込めて
作りました私たちはいつかこの靴下を履い
た人と後中ですれ違いたいよねと思ってい
ます
こんな明るいホームランチームなんですが
実は
リーダーになりたての頃私はホームラン
チームを止めたかったんです
ホームランをやることの意味がわから
なかったんです
そんなとき
それでも私が今も続けているのウェアー
できることやれることが見つかったから
です
リーダーになりたてのころの私はもうあ
スタンドも辞めたやめようと思っていた時
でした
そんなときに新聞取材に行ったんです
そしてあるお店に行った時
そのお店のオーナーは私たちに優しく
取材に応じてくれました
私は上がった後にありがとうございます
この新聞ができたらすぐ持ってきます
そして毎月この新ボート時に来てもいい
ですかと言いました
でも本当は心の中
私止めるぬ
4新聞はできないかもしれないもうお届け
に来れないかも
そう思っていました
その時最後にオーナーが言ったんです
ほーむらちんさん
どうか頑張ってください
実は私の子供はダウン症なんです
まだ小さいんです
その言葉を聞いて私は一瞬で
考え返した言葉があ
ホームラン新聞見てください
法村にはダウン症のまりさんがいます
彼女すごく頑張ってるんですよ
彼女の活躍をどうか見てくださいホーム
ランチームの明るい活躍をどうか新聞毎月
届けるんでどうか見てください
明日にでもやめようと思っていた私なのに
思いっきり力を込めて言ってしまっていた
んです
私はこの人の奥さんが毎日つらい思いをし
ているんじゃないかなと思ってしまいまし
た
障害4の障害があるお子さんを
産んだ時母親ら自分を責めます
私たちの子供が何でしょうが今って生まれ
たんだろう
私の何がいけなかったんだろう
妊娠中に反したことをこうしたこと
いろんなことを考えて公開しそして自分を
否定して攻めます
だから私はホームランチームが希望の光に
なって
枚毎月このホームランの活躍を新聞を
届けることでこのお母さんを励ましたい
そう思ったんです
それから毎月毎月
届けました
ですが
毎回従業員サニ新聞を渡すだけ
果たしてオーナーにも奥さんにも届いて
いるのかそんなこともわからず毎月届けた
んです
そして1年ほどが経過しました
各館でイベント販売を新聞を並べてして
ましたすると一人の女性が近づいてきたん
です
そして私に言いました
ホームランチームさんですか私この新聞
知ってます
毎月読んでるんです
そしてホームランチームさんに励まされて
いるんです
なんとこの女性はオーナーの奥さんだった
んです
あったこともないその人に私たちは力を
上げたく毎月新聞を届けてました
初めて会ったその女性は笑顔はとっても
素敵な人でした
私はうれしくなりました
ホームランチームができることやれること
それは人に力を与えることができるんです
そしてこんな出会いもありました
私は支援学級にお子さんを通わせてる
お母さんと友達になりました
その子は当時中学生ナナちゃん
自閉症です
お母さんは毎日毎日7ちゃんと向き合って
頑張ってます
私はその時
10日ホームランチームのフェイスブック
見てほしいそう伝えました
するとお母さんは見てくれてそして私に
言ったんです私
みいさんを知ってます
小学校の時だけど
めいちゃんはちょっとも変わらないみい
さんはがんばってるのねと
なんとこの女性は名産の小学校の時の先生
だったんです
メイさんとが少ししか変わらなかったから
私のことを覚えてないでしょうけど
と彼女は言いました
彼女が名産を受け持たれた後結婚して退職
しました
でもそして子供を産んだんですそれがナナ
ちゃん芽衣ちゃんと同じ自閉症でした
私はメイちゃんに聞きました
みーちゃん
小学校の時の担任の先生と覚えている
そして
名前に a が付くんだけど
メイさんは覚えてますと言って頭文字一つ
だけで先生の名前を言い当てたんです
さて明さんは記憶力抜群です
忘れるわけがありません
そして明さんは私に教えてくれました当時
先生が自己紹介をした時のこともそして
先生はとっても騎乗だったこと
私は名産にめちゃのねー
私ね生成と友達になったのよ
先生はね名産の活躍がとっても嬉しいのだ
からメイさん
生成にメッセージ動画送ってもいいかなっ
て聞きましたメイさんはいいですよと言っ
て動画を撮らせてくれました
先生お元気ですかメインは元気です
先生私一生懸命とお仕事頑張ってます
どうか先生も子育て頑張ってください
私はそれを先生に送りました
先生はかつての教え子に今も励まされて
いるんです
これがホームランチームにできるすごい
ことです
ホームランチームは支えられてばかりじゃ
ない人に元気と勇気を与えるチームなん
です
そしてひとつ思い知らされたことがあり
ました
私は
農園のお野菜を使ったお料理京数を
イベントで企画したことがありますその
イベントが一般客向けのイベントでした
私は良かれて上がってホームランチームと
そしてナナちゃん親子を誘うたんですナナ
ちゃんは大喜びで大はしゃぎでした
ですがお母さんは気にするんです
うちの子が騒がしくでごめんなさい
うるさくてすみません邪魔してごめん
なさい
謝ってばかりなんです
私はこんなに肩身の狭い思いをするんだ
なぁと思いました
この子たちの居場所をつくりたい
いろんなことができる場所をつくりたい
そう思いました
私たちは会社を辞めました
ですが今もつながった農家の方の畑に
手伝いに行ったり絵を書いて作品グッズを
作ったりしています
そして昨年10月にホームランの展覧会を
開きました
繋がりに感謝をしみんなで幸せになる展覧
会です
新メンバーを増員しました
以前農園体験をしたことがある立沢自閉症
です
そしてもちろんナナちゃん
今高校3年生になりました
これまでつながった方々にたくさん協力し
てもらいました
開催する場所もも書く場所もたくさんの人
に協力してもらって加勢してもらって
そして楽しんでもらいました
こうやって楽しく
笑いながら炊いてますはいそして
展覧会は大成功でたくさんのホームランの
ファンが来てくれました
関わった人以上に人が人を選んで
そして集まってきてくれたんです
皆さんに感謝です